or the trial of an alleged serial killer
known as the Hollywood Ripper is
underway in Los Angeles prosecutors say
Michael Gargiulo attacked for women with
a knife killing three of them his
alleged crimes go back to 1993 and
stretch halfway across the country 48
hours correspondent Maureen Maher has
been covering this story for more than a
decade she's outside the Cook County
prosecutor's office in Chicago
Maureen good morning good morning
Anthony so why am i standing in front of
a County Jail in Chicago instead of the
one in Los Angeles where Michael
Gargiulo is awaiting day two of his
trial
that's because investigators say this is
where the accused serial killer got
started and it won't come to an end
until he is back here to face a judge
and jury michael Gargiulo sat without
emotion listening to prosecutors
described him as a serial sexual thrill
killer he watched and collected
real-time intelligence on the victims
and then manipulated the circumstances
to provide himself with the perfect
opportunity to pounce and kill in blitz
type knife attacks prosecutors accused
43 year-old Gargiulo of murdering three
women including 22-year old Ashley
Ellerman who was friendly with Hollywood
actor Ashton Kutcher on the night of the
2001 killing Kutcher went to Ellen's
home to pick her up for a party but left
after she didn't answer the door Ellen's
body was found the next morning outside
her bathroom Ashlee had been stabbed
over 47 times Kutcher has avoided
talking publicly about the case but he
is expected to be called as a witness
during the trial investigators believe
the killing actually started eight years
earlier they say in 1993 Gargiulo killed
his neighbor while living in Illinois
the body of 17 year old Tricia Picacho
was found on her back doorsteps by her
father Gargiulo grabbed Tricia snapped
her arm and stabbed her repeatedly
Boccaccio's murder went unsolved until
40
ours mystery aired this report on her
case in 2011 following the broadcast two
new witnesses came forward within weeks
Gargiulo was charged in connection with
her 1993 death after Gargiulo moved to
Los Angeles police say the former
handyman and boxer found new victims in
2005 he allegedly killed 32 year old
Maria Bruno a mother of four who lived
in his apartment complex this muffled
9-1-1 call reveals the moments after
Gargiulo allegedly attacked then 26
year-old Michelle Murphy in 2008 Murphy
who'd been woken up to someone stabbing
her managed to fight off her attacker
and survived Gargiulo was later arrested
after prosecutors say his DNA was found
at the scene Gorge alone could face the
death penalty in California but
regardless of the verdict out west the
Pecan she owes who live here in suburban
Chicago had been told by the Cook County
State's Attorney's office he will be
immediately transferred back here once
everything wraps up in LA to face murder
charges in the 26 year now long saga for
this family they've been waiting a
couple of decades to have justice for
their daughter's murder glad and
hopefully that justice will come Maureen
thank you very much